come back retour de la méche bonsoir
c'est un enfant du siècle qui vient de
mourir assassiné ce matin à new york
john lennon avait 40 entre juste pour ce
tournage pour les plus jeunes aussi
c'était à sa manière un témoin de son
époque bruyant et nostalgie qui nous
laissera tous le souvenir d'au moins un
disque un parmi les 250 millions vendus
depuis quinze ans dans le monde entier
ce sont ces quelques-uns de ces millions
de francs que vous avez vu ici murmure l
une de ses dernières chansons devant son
domicile
c'est là en effet que s'est déroulé le
drame la nuit dernière
il projetait
toutes les télévisions et les chaînes de
radios américaines ont interrompu leurs
programmes pour annoncer la mort de john
lennon la nouvelle s'est répandue comme
une traînée de poudre dans les rues de
new york et plusieurs centaines de ses
admirateurs ont veillé toute la nuit
devant son domicile luxueux 3 bordure de
central park
les larmes aux yeux écoutant à la radio
ou sur des cassettes des dernières
chansons de john lennon ils ont évoqué
dans la nuit new yorkaise le temps où
avec les beatles il débarquait pour la
première fois aux états unis au sommet
de sa gloire
les admirateurs de lennon se demande
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi ce jeune
américain de 25 ans david chapman a tiré
à bout portant sur john lennon alors
qu'il rentrait chez lui avec sa femme
après une séance d'enregistrement un
maniaque un admirateur déçus qu'ils
cherchaient désespérément des
autographes
pas de mobile apparent dit la police de
new york qui vient pourtant d'ouvrir une
enquête dans l'entourage du chanteur
l'assassinât de lennon a en tout cas
autant d'impact ici aux etats-unis que
la mort d'elvis presley
oui pour beaucoup john lennon c'était la
tête pensante de ce groupe qui ne
s'était plus réunie sur une scène depuis
des années ce soir aucun de ses trois
amis dispersés pour la vie n'a jamais
encore vous lui parlez pas plus paul
maccartney que george harrison ou ringo
starr gérard us nous rappellera en fin
de journal qui furent les beatles et qui
fut donnée note